france24 y la unesco presenta
[Música]
bienvenidos a patrimonio en común un
programa especial de france 24 en
colaboración con la oficina de naciones
unidas para la cultura la educación y la
ciencia la unesco y me encuentro en un
sitio espectacular estoy en la antigua
ciudad de cartago patrimonio universal
de la humanidad desde 1979 estoy en la
costa mediterránea de túnez en el norte
de áfrica porque vamos a hablar
justamente del patrimonio de este país
rico en historia más de tres mil años de
historia pero para comenzar me encuentro
aquí con el historiador tunecino de
siria sirio buenos días
hola qué tal gracias por acompañarnos
feliz de estar en este lugar lleno de
historia de libro de historias y ya no
te ha perdido nostalgia la grandeza de
esa ciudad y su misión justamente aquí
es contarnos cuál fue la importancia de
cartago en la historia de nuestra
civilización bueno su importancia tiene
en primer lugar a los que han
construido que han creado esta estación
esta ciudad es decir los fenicios que
vinieron aquí a finales del siglo 9
antes de jesucristo y con la mítica
elisa han construido un poco más allá en
la colina diversa lo que va a
desarrollarse que constituir una ciudad
muy interesante y muy famosa en el mundo
desde entonces pero luego vinieron los
romanos los romanos se invadieron a los
púnicos los fenicios y reconstruyeron la
zona nuevamente porque bueno la
reconstruyeron después de destruirla y
después de echar el sal para
considerarla como una ciudad
pero después consideraron que su
importancia estratégica sobre todo no
permite a continuar a ignorarla y la
reconstruyeron durante el siglo primero
después de jesucristo y a partir de esa
fecha empezó carta con la romana a
constituir una ciudad
dijimos universal que tenía una
importancia en el mundo romano de
entonces una capital de casi
trescientos mil habitantes
son casi 500 hectáreas en qué lugar
preciso de esas 500 hectáreas nos
encontramos acuerdo precisamente no sé
qué entramos lo que se llama la colina
de los leones del teatro y en este lugar
encontramos lo que vimos que estamos
viendo ahora las villas las villas de
cartago y estamos precisamente en una de
ellas es la casa más famosa más rica que
se llama la casa a diaria a causa de las
músicas que están aquí en el atrium en
el patio y que está decorado con
diferentes pájaros finalmente decir
cuáles son las joyas que tiene cartago
para quien la visita bueno solo hasta
villas hay muchas muchas joyas de la
época púnica y de la época romana y
empezó rápidamente con quitar los
puertos que están enfrente a los puertos
los utilizó el plar porque hay el puerto
militar y el puerto comercial y también
hay las termas de antonino y la colina
divisa el teatro bueno muchas cosas que
están existiendo y seguro que si
continuamos las escalas
vamos a encontrar otras joyas muchas
gracias me apresuro caminando
rápidamente para llegar a ese hermoso
estudio que es france24 ha instalado en
este lugar que está lleno de historia
allí me esperan tres personas con
quienes vamos a conversar justamente
sobre el patrimonio de túnez pero antes
los invito a ver este vídeo animado que
preparó nuestro colega del castell para
saber de qué hablamos cuando hablamos de
patrimonio
estas ciudades han atravesado siglos
cairo han entonces esa huida en
marruecos o sitio prehistórico en
argelia en la tassili n'ajjer
la región de las montañas azules en
australia los monumentos de magaly pura
en india
todo eso es un patrimonio bienes
culturales naturales nacionales o
transfronterizos
la obra del arquitecto le cobije por
ejemplo está presente en distintos
países
un patrimonio es un bien que se hereda
un cuadro una joya pero también un bien
a una escala mayor la de un país incluso
a escala mundial
hablamos de patrimonio cultural y
natural
un patrimonio vivo
un tesoro que necesita ser protegido
[Música]
la organización de las naciones unidas
para la educación la ciencia y la
cultura unesco hizo un censo de los
sitios en peligro
está perdido se puede reparar lo que
está dañado
y mantener el patrimonio es también una
manera de proteger
y salvar el patrimonio es también salvar
la memoria humana
el patrimonio es un tesoro que debemos
proteger y para hablar de ese tesoro
estábamos aquí con miriam y rise borges
ella es profesora de historia del arte y
de la civilización de la universidad de
túnez y además una experta en la
transmisión del patrimonio muchas
gracias miran por acompañarnos estamos a
su derecha con karim en dili él es
responsable de cultura para el magreb de
la unesco gracias por acompañarnos ya su
izquierda ajuste de asia profesor
asociado de historia moderna de la
universidad de fax y además participa
del laboratorio de patrimonio de la
universidad de mal nuba en túnez y
también trabaja el tema del patrimonio
en la medina de túnez gracias a usted y
contigo vamos a comenzar husen porque
vamos a hablar de historia decíamos este
país tiene más de tres mil años de
historia una mezcla increíble aquí
pasaron estaban los bereberes vinieron
los púnicos o fenicios también nos
puedes explicar la diferencia estuvieron
los romanos los árabes los otomanos y
finalmente los franceses es casi una
mezcla única eso se refleja me imagino
en cada parte que vamos de túnez
encontramos patrimonio sobre todo
arqueológico
y por supuesto es un país muy rico de
historia y de civilizaciones de
patrimonio pero el patrimonio no
solamente arqueológico pero también un
patrimonio inmaterial pues muchas
civilizaciones han pasado del país desde
la época priísta de la prehistoria con
la civilización cristiana y luego los
autóctonos o los libros o los barberos
los milicianos que vinieron del ébano
los cartagos los romanos pues hasta los
bizantinos árabes otomanos y españolas
francesas pues como acaba de decir usted
es una mezcla de civilizaciones porque
tú no es porque tú ente está en un lugar
muy estratégico aquí estamos en cartago
casi estamos en el centro del
mediterráneo que controla la ciudad de
tunas de este sitio puedo controlar el
comercio de matrimonio entre el
mediterráneo occidental y oriental pues
todas estas civilizaciones han dejado
pues como el sitio de cartago si otros
sitios casi en toda la geografía de
itunes del norte hasta el sur de la
época
antigua y la época medieval
especialmente con los
árabes o los musulmanes hasta aquí
estamos hablar de la medina de túnez de
caixabank di susa de sfax de todos estos
sitios que tienen una gran historia
islámica hasta que pasamos con los
hermanos los otomanos especialmente
hablamos de la medina de túnez que es un
patrimonio también mundial y en la época
colonial francesa que deja también
muchos monumentos y sitios me parece que
vamos a discutir más sobre más adelante
exactamente porque también tenemos a
alguien de la onefa que se lo vamos a
preguntar pero mediante existe un libro
muy interesante muy bello además sobre
esos patrimonios algunos de sus
patrimonios que menciona ajusten pero
también crees que ese patrimonio como él
decía no es sólo arqueológico también es
inmaterial también se refleja en la
personalidad de los tunecinos yo había
terminado un doctorado y cuando viene
aquí a túnez
hice las rutas con salas rever que un
fotógrafo también conocido y empecé a
conocer este patrimonio nuestro todo lo
que el señor estaba diciendo no es la
misma cosa cuando uno va y visita y ve
los lugares los museos está en contacto
con la gente que vive al lado de los
sitios y cuando uno lee porque yo leí
muchísimo sobre túnez
yo estoy especializada en los mosaicos y
claro lo que me encanta más es estar en
contacto y se sentirá este amor sentir
también estas mezclas que tenemos en
todos los lugares en el país como usted
decía ahorita
yo pienso que el patrimonio es una cosa
la única cosa que está al final nosotros
nos vamos pero el patrimonio no el
patrimonio es la relación que tenemos
con el pasado la tenemos con el
patrimonio y pienso también que cada uno
puede recoger hacer una reconexión con
sí mismo para andar a buscar adentro
cuál es este patrimonio a mí me gustaría
la unesco le interesa mucho justamente
hacer énfasis en que el patrimonio no es
sólo arqueológico que es mucho más que
eso en túnez como se refleja cuál es ese
patrimonio inmaterial que tiene este
país bueno estamos a punto de celebrar
los 50 años de la convención de
patrimonio mundial será lo que viene en
2022 entonces tenemos décadas
de práctica y de experiencia
muestran que el patrimonio es un
concepto hoy en día más amplio hay
categorías de patrimonio por ejemplo que
ahora están integradas dentro de lista
de patrimonio mundial o también en las
listas nacionales de patrimonio y aquí
túnez por ejemplo podemos hablar el
patrimonio moderno patrimonio industrial
patrimonio de otras épocas y también
también por ejemplo el patrimonio
prehistórico los expertos nos recuerdan
que la prehistoria es 95% de nuestra
historia y durante años esos sitios
prehistóricos no eran tan bien
representados las del patrimonio mundial
y también una cosa muy importante que
usted ha mencionado que es la conexión
con otras formas de patrimonio y eso se
refleja a nosotros el trabajo de la
unesco el hecho que hay ahora conexiones
entre las convenciones común y mundial
pero también la convención para la
salvaguardia del patrimonio inmaterial
se celebra de unos días aquí en túnez
una conferencia importante sobre la
protección del patrimonio subacuático la
convención 2001 entonces esta
interacción es absolutamente esencial
para entender ese nuevo enfoque de
patrimonio y tener en este caso la buena
actitud y poner los buenos medios para
proponer las nuevas respuestas bueno en
medio incluso para proteger este
patrimonio arqueológico aquí hay cerca
dicen entre 30.000 y 50.000 sitios en
túnez sin embargo una sesentena están
protegidos este país vivió después de la
independencia de los gobiernos
autoritarios que parecían no entender
esa relación que tenían que tener con el
patrimonio
me gustaría justamente hablemos primero
del gobierno de burguiba no es cierto
sobre todo había un conflicto un poco
quizás con con el patrimonio francés que
destacaría de esa época bueno la verdad
hablar de la política del patrimonio
como cómo tratar el patrimonio en túnez
después la independencia no es algo
fácil y es algo un poco complicado no
podíamos hablar de una y un corto total
entre el período colonial
en el período colonial y luego con la
política deportiva me parece que está
una continuación pues la burguiba o el
gobierno condición después la
independencia ha conservado los los
institutos coloniales por ejemplo el
jump y el instituto nacional de
conservar el patrimonio bueno pero con
la llegada de la independencia
las autoridades o los tunecinos en
general han intentado más de trabajar
sobre el patrimonio islámico porque la
época colonial cuál es el francés los
franceses trabajan más sobre el
patrimonio romano podría decir que son
los hermanos son cristianos nosotros son
franceses cristianos entonces está esta
continuación pero con la independencia
los tunecinos también encuentran o
intentan demostrar que estaban en otro
patrimonio en túnez no está solamente el
cristiano está él
islámico miriam sí y luego vino el
gobierno del dictador ben alí y quizás
uno de los principales no sé si tú lo
piensas así expoliadores del patrimonio
tunecino cuando se embargaron sus
propiedades habían muchas piezas únicas
incluso que tenían el sello del yen ep
de lo que me recuerdo es que había
muchísimas
manifestaciones y conferencias
científicos que se encargaban de toda
vía de publicaciones me recuerdo también
es que había un banco mundial por
ejemplo que ha dado que hubo incentivo
pero es también justo en quizás hubo
muchas piezas que se perdieron en esa
época con sisi bueno el de hablar de
robo de los objetivos o los restos no es
algo nuevo podemos hablar de estilo en
mediados del siglo 19 pues éste empieza
especialmente con los franceses y los
ingleses pues están todos muy famosos
por ejemplo el caso dinero si es una
región arqueológico británico y 1857 que
exportó de este sitio de cartago casi 50
o algo más de cajas
a britannia entonces eso quiere decir
que el patrimonio tunecino siempre ha
estado un poco en fragilidad como cambio
eso quizás cariño cuando la unesco
declara los primeros tres sitios
patrimonio de la humanidad en 1979 que
significa que la unesco reconozca tres
lugares aquí en túnez como patrimonio de
la humanidad significa también una
protección si es un reconocimiento
universal es también la idea muy
importante que es una de las bases de la
convención de patrimonio mundial que es
un patrimonio compartido común que hay
que proteger y la responsabilidad
relacionada con esa protección y
salvaguardia es algo compartido entre
muchos actores no solamente a nivel
nacional pero también regional e
internacional
ahora también la cuestión de la
inscripción de sitios de patrimonio
mundial también es contribuir a
contar una historia esta historia la
humanidad y de nuestro nuestro planeta
también porque no olvidamos que
patrimonio mundial es también de
patrimonio natural se trata de
patrimonio natural y entonces este libro
que se escribe cada día porque la
historia de la humanidad está en marcha
la evolución es permanente entonces esos
sitios entran en esta categoría pero
también y eso es en un cosa importante
son también una nada una especie de
puerta abierta para la protección
patrimonio en general entonces dónde se
espera de un sitio como éste por ejemplo
o sitios patrimonio mundial en túnez es
que
se usen también para la protección del
patrimonio más allá de los límites de
esos bienes e incluir otras formas de
patrimonio etcétera que permite una cosa
sobre el patrimonio colonial
negocio de patrimonio mundial también es
una herramienta esencial para la manera
de concebir al patrimonio porque nuestro
patrimonio también incluye
periodos oscuros de nuestra historia
entonces no solamente son las maravillas
de las maravillas de la historia a nivel
estético arquitectónico etcétera termina
aquí la primera parte de nuestra emisión
y nos volvemos a encontrar dentro de
algunos minutos